the jurogan experience in your
documentary
you did a race you tried to do a an
icarus which is amazing documentary if
you haven't seen it i recommend it
highly you did a race clean and then you
were gonna do a race all juiced up
and you went to him and he was the head
of the russian anti-doping
federation is that what it is yeah so so
gregory rachankov
um basically the premise was um
is is i i felt that the entire
doping system in sport was a fraud
and and the reason why i i had this
belief was
is i'd i'd followed lance armstrong my
whole life a guy confesses in 2013 but
if you had actually followed that story
it's kind of like what you're saying
about you know russia's ban from the
olympics but
they're not really banned and they just
can't wear their outfit well
in the case of of lance well yeah he
confessed to doping
but the guy to this day never was
actually
caught and here's this guy had passed
like i don't know
five six hundred tests so as he
confesses and i'd been a cycling fan a
lifelong cyclist i'm going wait wait
wait um
you caught the guy based on a criminal
investigation
but you didn't catch him based on the
science and if you can't test the most
and if you can't catch the most tested
athlete on planet earth
well what does this mean for every other
athlete on planet earth and so
the idea was as i was going to do like a
super size me in the world
in the world of of sport
i was going to race clean and then the
next year i was going to dope the hell
out of myself
take testosterone hgh epo
i mean hcg
i was up to do anything i mean i was
i was literally like injecting myself
with like
you know it was like uh 10 syringes a
day it was just so stupid and uh
and then literally like i'm going to
getting blood tests to like build my
biological passport to like test my
hematocrit so like every other week i'm
literally going to get my blood drawn
i'm pissing to like you know build like
my whole steroid profile
to basically try to evade testing so
i get connected to this guy gregory
rachankov and at the time he's running
rusada which is the i'm sorry the water
lab
the world anti-doping lab uh for moscow
which is like the third largest
uh you know anti-doping lab in the world
at the time
this is now uh 2014 20 2015
and gregory bases like yes i'll help you
dope
and i'll help you evade testing and uh
i'll basically show you how you can game
the system
and i'm like this is nuts
like the guy who just did
all the testing for the sochi olympics
and is running
the entire anti-doping lab in russia is
basically going to like test my samples
and show me how to cheat
like what's going on here so
the two of us start working he comes to
the united states he comes to los
angeles we have a great time i then go
do this next race
completely doped out of my mind and i'm
like taking blood samples i'm taking
urine
and right after this race i hop on a
plane i go to moscow
and i'm like hanging out with gregory
for like a month
and he takes all my samples into the lab
and there was this investigation already
going on and i was like okay something's
off here
and so i spend this month in russia and
i come back what was the investigation
that was already going on
so in uh in the in
2015 um
wada releases in the i can't remember
exactly when it was it was like
early uh like
march of 2015 something like that the
world anti-doping agency
had already been investigating the
moscow laboratory
and they come out with this uh
with this report that they believe
that gregory richekov is like the
mastermind of this
space state sponsored doping operation
and they've got a bunch of evidence but
they had no
idea it was like i mean they had like
literally like the tip of a pinky and
and the size of the scandal was
basically you know
like an entire an entire body i mean
they literally just had the tip of the
pinky
but the temp of the pinky was so bad
that they
shut down the moscow lab gregory is now
the fall guy he's forced to resign
and you know and putin's basically on
television going like
look look whatever you want to believe
none of this is true
we've never doped we don't cheat these
are all lies
oh and by the way he says
anybody who is responsible for this
crime
will be punished so basically
putin is literally on television going
gregory rachankov is
is going under the bus and gregory
is in moscow and we had you know been
working together he calls me up and he's
like
but i am brian i need to escape and i'm
like um
uh okay when he's like now i need to
leave now
and i'm like uh like like now like as
and now
he's like yes yes i need a flight now
and
i'm literally sitting there on skype and
i start doing a search for
moscow los angeles and i'm like
well uh there's there's a flight in like
12 hours and he's like
okay i'm like you want me to book that
flight he's like yes book the flight if
i put it on my credit card they'll know
you'll have to put it on your credit
card
so i literally booked this flight put it
on my credit card
and a day later here's gregory in los
angeles
and about a month into him being in l.a
and you know
shit's going down in russia i'm like
look man you got to tell me
what happened and he opens up
and you know and that's was icarus i
mean it was
it's amazing it was crazy the way it
unfolded
in the documentary it's it couldn't have
been
written better like if it was a drama it
was a scripted drama it could not have
been written better and the fact that it
was all just
circumstance just all happened all
happened at the right time it's an
amazing documentary and
for a person like jordan burroughs who
was here yesterday it
it was too much he literally had to shut
it off i told i convinced him to watch
the rest of it
i go you have to i go it's so good it's
so crazy
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience